introverts are cool
period yet totally no biases there just
because i consider myself one on a
serious note though anime shown us that
despite not shouting out friendship or
resolved speeches compared to their
louder cousins
introverts in anime also tend to be as
badass as they can be
perhaps it's because a lot of them have
a more stable foundation drawing
strength from their own beliefs within
instead of from friends or their mentors
perhaps it's also because it's just more
surprising to see the quiet
emotionless guy unload an ass kicking
for the ages to a hapless foe
whatever it is i just find anime
introverts really cool and badass and
for today
i want to introduce you to some of my
favorites however for today we'll not
have this done in the form of a
countdown video
i won't be ranking these eight
characters because i want to give them
equal shine in this newer format of
video that i've been doing the past few
months or so
so before we start the video i'd like to
encourage you to hit the subscribe
button
each subscribe means so much to me and i
want nothing better than to grow the
channel with your help
let's work together to make this the
number one anime countdown channel on
youtube shall we it may be an effect of
the seasonal cycle and recency bias but
i'd like to start things off with rye
nombre's lead is pretty much what the
stereotypical image of a badass anime
introvert is
dark broody handsome and very very much
overpowered overpowered alone doesn't
seem to do justice to this ageless noble
with a plethora of insane powers and a
limitless amount of swagger he mostly
keeps to himself but cross him and
you'll find yourself in a world of
regret at the hands of his vampiric
powers this is one
awesome and badass introverted anime and
i just can't get enough of right you can
catch right in nobles but have to warn
you about something beforehand
you have to watch the prequel ova if you
intend to watch the series because the
series did the weird thing
where much of the introduction arc was
skipped a lot of people were caught off
guard by this
and i think that's too bad if they drop
the series because of this decision they
won't be able to see right
at his peak awesomeness
a lot of these anime introverts find
themselves in schools and what better
series to pick our next spotlight
character than from my hero academia the
funny thing about my hero academia is
that with its slew of characters with
colorful personalities and traits it
would be easy to pick a badass introvert
among them and while there's a lot of
them i'm leaning towards tamaki amajiki
for this list i mean how could you not
after seeing what kind of powers he has
his hero name
sunita is more than fitting given how he
can eat anything and manifest powers
from them it's not every day we get to
see this kind of twist on the mechanic
of bodily transformation powers talk
about kirby in overdrive
outside battle i also find him a very
interesting character i mean there are a
lot of introverts with awesome
backstories of their own like todoroki
but i personally resonate the most with
amajiki due to his cynicism he's just so
socially awkward that you can't help but
want to give him a hug or some words of
encouragement
although he'll probably just turn those
away the way he usually does
speaking of people that you can't help
but want to comfort
next we have homura
when she was first introduced to the
series homura is pretty much the
standoffish rival character you'd expect
to find in a magical girl anime quiet
frank to a fault and seemingly lacking
intact
or while she efficiently guns down and
destroys enemies without breaking a
sweat
and looking all badass and fabulous
while doing it all this earns her little
friendship points and love from the
other magical girls and she gets down in
bitter confrontations with sayaka in
particular but
i'd like to think that behind every
person like that there's an equally
troubling backstory somewhere and i
think the homura has one of the most
heart-wrenching ones i don't want to
spoil much of madoka magicka but i'll
just say that if you've been through the
amount of [ __ ] homura has it's not
surprising to end up the way she is you
should go and watch it and proceed with
rebellion which despite not being my
favorite
way to unofficially end the series caps
off homura's very well crafted character
[Music]
arc
[Music]
while maura is a master of keeping her
emotions in check have you seen someone
double time on that i mean he's someone
whose powers are completely tied to how
he's feeling
yep i'm talking about none other than
mob real name
shigeoka guyama unassuming and rather
awkward mom's someone who actively
avoids losing control of his emotions
and can you blame him i mean mob's whole
shtick is that his powers rely on his
emotions
and out of control feelings means people
get hurt as you can already tell that's
not the easiest task in the world
especially if you're someone who's quite
socially awkward like mob is having
trouble reading the atmosphere and
interacting with people in public is the
least of this compassionate hero's
worries
it's these traits that make it such a
joy to see mob in his flashes of heroism
where he overcomes the shell and taps
into his psychic powers to help save the
world it makes him even more of a badass
to unleash the various modes of his
powers
in spite of all the psychological and
emotional barriers that should have made
those difficult if not downright
impossible
mob is truly a joy to watch as a
character and that's what makes mob
psycho 100 such a great show
but you know what doesn't make a good
show pesky region locks
enter the sponsors of this video
expressvpn
it sure must be a pain to go to
crunchyroll or funimation then run into
the dreaded region lock message with
expressvpn's amazing service
you can connect to so many different
proxy servers from all over the world
that way you can access anime just like
the more privileged people in the world
i started using expressvpn and i never
looked back
why because it's by far the best value
you can get for a vpn service
and it's also the easiest to use want to
watch attack on titan on netflix
just open expressvpn and change the
location to united kingdom and there you
go
you can finally watch some titan slaying
goodness on netflix
in case you run into more advanced
problems you can access the live chat
function to get someone to answer your
questions in real time
here let me help you out by giving you
three months free and all you have to do
is click the link below
or just go to expressvpn.com
[Music]
for some reason there's one character
that i always associate with mob
nope it's not the strongest bald hero in
the universe but another badass
introvert with psychic powers
if you guess psychic also you're
absolutely correct i just can't separate
mob psycho and psychic
apart for reasons more obvious to some i
mean both of introverted characters who
have psychic abilities both of them also
really take good care of their emotions
in fear of hurting others badly however
psyche is more of a stoic dude than
someone more socially awkward like
mob as for who's the better one amongst
them well i can't really tell but
both are amazing in their own ways i do
feel that psyche is a bit rough around
the edges and he comes with his own
sharp tongue full of snark he also
actively keeps people at bay compared to
the former how badass
is psyche really just look at the entire
gallery of powers and tell me that's not
an awesome character don't worry though
it's all played for laughs most of the
time instead of making him an
overpowered character that's meant to be
taken too seriously
who says badass introverts in anime are
limited to humans ligoshi's here to
prove you wrong being a carnivore with
such a fearsome reputation would do a
number on anyone striving to just come
to terms with the world around them as
such
ligoshi ends up being a quiet withdrawn
and sensitive wolf along with that comes
some quirks
like struggling to connect with others a
fascination with certain items
and particular attention to detail in
any other world people would think of
him as that wimpy weirdo in school
however when push comes to shove negoshi
has shown himself to have one of the
strongest wills and hearts in the b
stars universe
push the right buttons and you'll
quickly see why messing with one of the
coolest and most formidable predators in
the animal kingdom
is a bad idea you wouldn't want those
fangs bared on those who dare hurt his
friends now do you i really can't wait
for more b stars because having read the
manga i think that the goshii has so
much more cool moments in addition to
what we've already seen from him in the
anime form he's really one
amazing protagonist that for me carries
the story in such a strong way
introverts by definition often come with
some traits like strict adherence to
rules and honor as well as masterful
skill hiding their emotions none embody
that specific combination more than
is one of the best characters in bleach
he's the pure embodiment of the
honorable samurai lord archetype in
bleach and his code of honour is second
to none even in a place like seoul
society however what makes him such a
great character for me are two factors
one is his backstory and his care for
rookier despite his facade the entire
development of his complicated
relationship with rookier is one of my
favorite pieces of character building in
the entirety of bleach the second reason
i like him is due to just how
awesome his powers are in battle don't
let the pink petals and the flowery
aesthetics drop your guard else you'll
be facing death in the form of a vortex
of pain it's not as broken as the powers
of someone like
say isaac but it does look loads cooler
biakuya can even modify
senbonzakura's attacks to manifest in
the form of a hall of swords or a single
gigantic blade
the few can match
[Music]
last but not least how could we forget
the greatest detective in the world
l when you think of the words anime
introvert taken to the extreme you get
elle's appearance
coming with his own set of weirdness and
mannerisms but highly intelligent and
cunning elves the embodiment of a person
who pretty much threw all his stats on
intelligence
instead of spreading more of them out
evenly and that makes him the perfect
match for the megalomaniac genius known
as kira
to be fair it's the traits like the
fondness for sweets or the signature sit
that make l such a fan favorite there's
no more fitting rival for light
throughout death notes run there's just
no one who can match light in terms of
intelligence and willingness to do
anything to one of the other
a joking opinion that's gotten traction
over the years is that the story of
death note
took a massive nose dive the moment
their rivalry ended without the perfect
main character and the perfect rival
death note is nothing and i'm inclined
to agree
[Music]
[Applause]
so how about your favorite badass anime
introverts
care to introduce some of them to me
i'll be waiting on the comments section
for your suggestions and i'd love to
have a discussion with you about anime
introverts in general
before you go don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to the channel once
again i'm asking you to subscribe
because it will help this channel grow
so much and allow me to share more anime
goodness with the rest of youtube
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video expressvpn
bypass all those pesky region locks and
even browse sites not available in your
region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now
thank you for your support and
see you next time
[Music]
you